let me make one thing clear architecture
and engineering are two very different
professions one without the other is a
recipe for disaster an architecturally
designed home with a lack of engineering
input may be doomed in years to come
whilst an engineering masterpiece
without any architectural input may lack
the fundamental essentials making it an
enjoyable environment to live in let's
start with architecture architecture is
the arts or practice of designing and
constructing buildings as architects we
are trained to design around the human
experience
to explore all factors interacting with
the built form which contribute to the
quality of everyday life good
architecture is often subliminal and
unappreciated you won't realize how
carefully thought out each detail is
until you are overwhelmed and confused
in a space that lacks the basic
architectural principles architects
focus on the environmental and
psychological factors surrounding the
design from the sun paths and the wind
paths to the impact of color on mood our
role is to ensure a house feels like a
home that it is comfortable and
practical whilst at the same time spaces
of vocal motion and forms follow
function we draw upon the surrounding
information to form colour palettes
organic shapes and unique stories around
the climate aspiring to create a
dwelling that is as unique as they are
often an architect's role is to
coordinate all design professionals in
the project this could be one consultant
or over a dozen at any given time
architects are traditionally very
creative individuals but to be
successful in architecture we tend to
spend a large portion of our time
discussing laws in the end we are often
manipulating our original ideas to suit
these constrictions architects also
manage the building contracts during
construction for clients ensuring that
neither party is being taken advantage
of that the design is coming to life as
imagined and that the project stays on
time and on budget if you're looking for
a checklist to help you with your
architectural designs from sketch to
construction documentation be sure to
check out the links in the description
and download your very own digital
checklist engineers on the other hand
are often brilliant people they are
traditionally trained in one or two
areas be it structural civil electrical
hydraulic or even mechanical engineering
as an example it is very rare that one
engineer is both educated and qualified
in all fields when it comes to
residential architecture structural
engineers are the most common so we will
focus on them structural engineers are
trained to design the bones and muscles
of the built form their precise
calculations ensure that the ideas of an
architect stand the test of time good
structural engineers know the exact
tension and breaking point of each
structural element thus knowing exactly
how far to push the boundaries without
ever tipping the balance that little bit
too far structural engineers focus on
the construction and buildability of the
design whilst factoring in elements such
as live loads and dead loads a live load
for example is considered to be people
or goods in a building things that are
ever changing and ever moving vehicles
are something that would be considered a
live load dead loads are often permanent
they will always be there and they are
often unchanged but don't be fooled
structural engineers aren't just worried
about the elements they specify or the
people interacting with the building
they also have to consider mother nature
at her worst structural engineers are
the reason buildings stand the test of
time while skyscrapers don't fall down
during earthquakes structural engineers
are the mortar to the brick without them
even the best design will eventually
crumble a good structural engineer is
worth their weight and their fee in gold
if you're new here my name is david
tomic and on this channel we talk all
things architecture and technology if
that is something that interests you
there aren't too many architecture
channels here on youtube so be sure to
subscribe to the channel hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and as
always i'll see you next monday